o fígado é um herói silencioso no corpo
ele é responsável por mais de 500
funções vitais você sabia que 25% da
população tem gordura no fígado e nem
sabe mesmo quem não consome álcool em
excesso pode ter essa condição existe
suplementos que podem ajudar Bergamota e
Alcachofra pode reduzir em até 15% a
gordura do fígado em apenas 12 semanas a
Bergamota é uma fruta cítrica rica em
polifenóis que ajuda a quebrar as
gotículas de gordura no fígado Além
disso Combate o stresse oxidativo e
melhora a função hepática já o cachorro
ela reduz o acúmulo de gordura no fígado
e combate a inflamação e a cim marina
que é encontrada no Cardo Mariano
bloqueia toxinas e promove a Regeneração
celular o dente de leão atua como
diurético natural e elimina toxinas o
nac é essencial para produzir glutationa
o antioxidante mais poderoso que o nosso
corpo pode fabricar especialmente útil
para desintoxicar o fígado então esses
suplementos são uma estratégia
inteligente mas não fazem Milagres
sozinhos os de Vida Saudável para que
seu fígado possa recuperar corretamente
Não deixe de assistir o vídeo longo
relacionado